nice guy issues come from anxious
attachment style he grew up afraid of
his mother abandoning him so all he
knows is how to earn good boy points and
approval to avoid abandonment that's
never going to make any woman happy this
is why nice guys finish last o and you
really liked that other tweet I did with
the uh the werewolf and the happy puppy
nice guys look really fluffy at first
and then really vicious at the end of it
when when you reject them it's because
they earn good boy points and they are
supposed to be rewarded
they do nice things for you expecting to
be repaid and you have to figure out
what they want it's usually sex you have
to figure out what they want and do it
for them or they will be ve furiously
angry that you didn't reciprocate the
way the rules say that you have to this
is why nice guys finish last is because
they just can't ask and they will come
off as a jerk
eventually you've seen this before I'm
sure you have absolutely I mean there's
a really great article by Vincent
harinam about um
the the E social economics of sing and
what he's talking about is that a man
who is to pliable is kind of the same as
a woman who gives up sex too easily that
the thing you know if you presume that
the the highest value thing that a woman
can offer a man like Beyond commitment
and love and like all of the actual like
importance stuff but like as a
front face resources and Chastity right
the it's the trade largely that that is
part of one of the main trades that gets
made and a woman who gives up Chastity
without commitment is people are
skeptical of her and a man who gives up
resources without sex in return people
are also skeptical of him it's why I
think there is an awful lot of social
stigma around men who subscribe to only
fans men who give gifts on Amazon gift
lists and stuff like like that because
what those men are doing is they're
offering up something which was supposed
to be gate kept and walled off for all
men to like stand firm we are all one
unit and if the women don't give us sex
then they don't get our resources and
what you have now is a man who is
prepared to give up resources without
sex in the same way as a woman who's
prepared to give up sex without
commitment gets criticized by a lot of
women women who give up sex without
commitment drive down the market price
or the market value of sex to a level
where all other women need to meet it if
you are prepared to give up a on
the first date and I want to wait until
the third date I now need there's a
price differential I now need to uh
degrade my own uh price my own the value
that I see my at down to that
first date and the same thing occurs
with men if in order for a man to give
up his resources and be able to
financially support a woman the woman
needs to jump through a bunch of Hoops
that keeps the value of resources High
whereas and this is another one of the
reason I think that there is a
particular amount of distaste from both
men and women toward only fans uh
creators that they see them as getting a
free ride and they see them as
capitalizing off the back of men who are
overly pliable men aren't happy with
either the men or the women because they
look at the women and think well I'm
never going to be able to get her
because what can I offer her that 10,000
men all combined how can I compete with
10,000 men's worth of resources and the
women aren't aren't happy with her
either because it seems like she's well
she there's a lot of intersexual
competition going on there so yeah the
the um resources thing the over
pliability of of men and it's
fundamentally why sing doesn't work like
you
may let's take that even one step
further is you we're hunter gatherers
more than anything our brains haven't
even caught up to the Neolithic
Revolution and the ideas of surplus and
anything so safety protection out in the
world um let's take the let's take it
one step further your your audience they
love historical examples so let's talk
about Vikings right the Danes a thousand
years ago raiding up and down the coasts
all over the Britain all over the UK um
the Danes if they sailed in you don't
want to be married to the guy that when
the Danes roll in they're like we demand
women and he's like well okay here's my
wife here's my daughter all right guys
sorry like you have to go live with the
Danes now you don't want that guy you
want the guy who plants his flag and
says this will never happen I'm going to
die first me and all the other guys are
going down to the beach to die for you
guys so that hopefully we will drive the
cost so high that they will leave if I
don't see you again I love you bye-bye
and he goes to die to protect his family
that's simps are gonna be like oh man
like well I'm really sorry I'm thinking
of um also another historical example um
there was a gentleman during the
Holocaust that he sent his own wife and
kids on the train knowing knowing what
was going to happen to them he was
sending people on the train he put his
own wife and kids on the train when it
was their turn didn't say anything just
loaded them on the wife and the on the
train and ship them away and after the
war when they had the tribunals when
they did everything they grab they found
him they found him much later on in life
and they brought him in and they put him
up on trial and he said there is nothing
you can do to me than is that is worse
than me living with the memory of what I
did to my wife and to my
children but he that was that right
there was a moment of why you don't
marry a s that is why women don't
respect simps that's why they don't
don't respect nice guys is the more
agreeable you are it's not just the
agreeableness even it's the weaker you
are for approval for safety you
prioritize your own safety over actually
taking a stand for your morals that's
why Viking raids the Holocaust even all
the way back to just raiding tribes in
in in hunter gatherer times it's safety
that's what women understand that's why
they need to respect a man before they
really sleep with a man long term every
single morning for over 3 years now I
have started my day the exact same way
which is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium pottassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA liting and
relied on by tons of Olympic athletes
and everyday High performers all around
the world also there is a no BS no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy a box completely risk-free and
if you do not like it for any reason
they will give you a refund during an
unlimited duration and you don't even
need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it
element are giving away a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box if you go to the link in the
description box below or drink LM nt.com
MW that's drink LM nt.com
/mw what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to
subscribe